Recent proposals to expand and reform the child
tax credit have gained significant attention
in Congress. When considering such reforms it's
important to understand the tax benefits currently
available. The federal income tax provides a
number of family tax benefits – including the
head-of-household filing status, and tax credits
for children and child care expenses. In 2021
the total value of these benefits is $ 209 billion
and the average benefit per household
with children is almost $4600. This includes
a $2,000 partially refundable child tax credit.
The distribution of these benefits is highly
progressive, meaning that lower-income households
receive a larger benefit relative to their income
than higher-income households. Current proposals
would increase the child tax credit and make
the credit fully refundable, meaning the credit is
available regardless of income. Therefore, these
proposals all reduce poverty rates. Unfortunately,
by eliminating the phase-in of the credit, these
proposals would also raise marginal tax rates on
work for low-income households with children.
Should Congress expand the child tax credit?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.